you mentioned uh early on heartbreak
after the Russia trip with a girl who
slept with your friend
uh let's go back to Hemingway quotes
the best way to find out if you can
trust somebody is to trust them
so to go all in with the trust
I love Hemingway so much
um
have you been betrayed in your life yeah
what do you think about trust
that's an interesting question
um
I've been betrayed in my professional
life a couple times by really close
friends
and uh
I'm not someone who can't like I have a
mantra that I mean I'm
I don't know if people have heard it or
not and I hate I hate sharing it but
it's but it's true the Mantra is so you
think I'm weak
like do you think it's like that's my
thing because I I feel like people take
advantage of me and I go so you think
I'm weak
you forget everyone that like that and
I'm named the the people that have
betrayed me I'm a larger man than all of
them and and but I and so that's what
really [__] with me is I go so you
think I'm weak like where I grew up when
you do stuff there was physical
consequences I grew up in Florida like
I've been beaten up a bunch I'm not
saying I can fight but like I'm not
scared of getting beaten up
and the the times that I've been
betrayed and and
even I know even like by Ari whichever
people see that drugging as a betrayal
and I did for a period but it was it was
only because it was Ari and he was my
one of my best friends and me and him
had to work through that because I I
couldn't not love him like I couldn't
not have him in my life he means a lot
to me he really does he's a great friend
to have
but he's also I don't know what was
going on with him at that time but he
made a bad decision and I had to forgive
him for that because I knew he he knew
my mantra
I think I'm harder to trust people now
I'm I'm not as apt to trust people at
all
but there was a moment I don't know if
I've ever shared this and I don't know
how this will sound but there was a
moment that information got leaked about
a thing and all my managers and agents
both both
Tom and my Tom and our managers and
agents would like to uh separate either
separate us
or one of us one of them get both of us
it's just more lucrative for them sure
so they have always kind of pitted us
against each other a little bit and they
do it subtly
um they'll do it to me and my team and
then his team will do it to me and then
my team will do it to him and his team
will do it to him
and there was a moment where information
got leaked about this thing I was doing
and my team was like just so you know
your your boy Tommy is is the rat and I
had to
it was the one time and Leanne said do
you think Tom would do that
I said uh I don't know how Faith Works
like I'm not a super religious person
but I will tell you that I believe in
Tom and I don't think he did it and I
will stand by that ignorantly
and and I will and I will ride or die
with him because I cannot live in a
world where I don't trust him yeah if I
don't trust him then I am so [__]
and uh and it wasn't him it wasn't him
and it was it's a cool feeling to know
that you could like
that you could blindly trust someone
blindly have faith in someone know that
they're they have your best interest in
art
but yeah it took me a while to get there
Rogan helped me get there because I
wasn't trusting him or Joey or Tommy or
anyone I wasn't trusting anyone I'd
gotten in a bad thing and I just wasn't
trusting anybody
Rogan was like yeah man we're trying to
be your [__] friend and I was like
yeah I don't I don't need friends
I couldn't understand what why Rogan was
interested in me and I said to like
someone was like is he gay like what the
[__] yeah and then he was just a nice
guy he was just a nice guy
that'd be hilarious if Joe was sexually
attracted to you this whole time this
whole time is the reason he keeps
inviting about I would be more excited I
would be more excited if just if he
tried to kiss me on the lips once just
and just and then like in a Scotty
Scotty J way from Boogie Nights where
he's like what do you like my car yeah
you know nobody would believe that story
no one yeah if I was Joe I would kiss
dudes all the time and then be like and
then and then when they didn't kiss back
oh you know but no one ever believe you
yeah well when you trust people like
that and they [__] you over that can
really really really hurt
you end up on a treadmill
in a hotel room
fighting with them you fight with them
all the time you fight with them all the
time
you fight with them constantly
and it's and I and I I have this uh
thing like where I can ruminate on an
idea and I can't get it out of my head
and I hear the words they say and then I
and
so all in your head on a treadmill in
your head just fighting just [__]
fighting and then yeah
and then one day you get past it like
one day you just go huh [__] them I'm
not gonna let you give them real estate
and then you just forget about them and
then they reach out and they'll try to
be a dick or a bully because they're
bullies they're bullies is what they are
don't ever forget it they're [__]
bullies and they got bullied it's not
their fault they got bullied
and then they try to Bull you and you
don't have any connection anymore and
you're like oh you can go [__] yourself
you can actually go [__] yourself you're
not my boss you're not my wife you don't
[__] me you don't pay me get the [__]
out of my life
but this kind of Mantra that you're not
weak you still want to be able to be
fragile to the world and appear weak
almost I am I am I mean that's the
problem is I think I am pretty [__]
weak like I think I'm not the strongest
dude out there I have really thin skin
might get my feelings hurt all the time
yeah and so but like but it sucks when
you watch like your friend
see something in you that you go
where they go ah [__] him he's not
paying attention
[__] him let's just [__] him let's take
his money you know what [__] him he
doesn't know what the [__] he's doing
look at me he's a drunk alcoholic and
you go oh no [__] I pay attention like
I'm I'm wide awake I'm here I'm working
my ass off you're not gonna [__]
well that's a tough thing about like you
and Tom Segura you're at the top of your
game on top of the world some of the
most famous comics in the world and
you could see money start to creep in
like uh business decisions yeah
I don't know it's a tough it's a tough
place it's really tough it's really
tough work you know especially as we're
growing
and and uh
I'll tell you what it
I don't know how much I'm allowed to say
but I can tell you this
with a business deal
where feelings were getting involved
and money was involved in that and the
money was causing the feelings
and one of us said
to the other person our feelings are
more important than the money so let's
just split the money and it was and it
was and it was and
it was it was really like a solid moment
where I where both of us were like that
is how we should run this yeah
that's the interesting things like with
bands you'll have like
popular bands that split and even yeah
even though it's clear that the
contribution is not even it's like uh
there's a front man and all that kind of
stuff but it's ultimately the right
thing to do to say [__] you to the money
for the most part and prioritize the
feelings yeah especially because like
I couldn't do it without him he couldn't
do it without me we do it separately
we'll have guest Bears on some will blow
up some won't you can never figure it
out but when we're together it does well
and so we need each other for it to work
and we've you know
like I said we're on a handshake deal
with two bears and no one likes that
but we're like hey
I mean we I don't like to the point
where like he'll call me and go yo we
have a deal to do this for x amount are
you in and I go yeah
I'll check the books I don't need to I
don't I don't I know him I just know him
yeah
what do you love most about Tom Segura
though we saw a gay couple one time this
is a good start and there was one guy
was in khakis and one guy was in jean
shorts with a python around his neck
yeah and Tom goes if we were gay which
one would you be I said I'm [__]
python yeah and he was like yeah I'm
khaki and I go really he goes yeah
that's why we work and he goes all
relationship for pythons and khakis and
I went really and he goes look at you
and Leanne who do you think you are
going bike on she's khaki and he goes me
and push I go oh she's python he goes
and I'm khaki there's always be khaki
and sometimes I'll have a relationship
around the python but it's I'm usually a
khaki yeah and I was like yeah I am a
little bit of a lunatic I'll tell you
the one of them a moment
that explains
me and him the world will never see it
was just a great moment we got stem
cells with Rogan one weekend yep and one
day
and I'd had surgery in my arm and Ty
didn't want to do it I was terrified and
Tom just said just come out and meet up
with us Tom knew he was going to make me
get them and so
I got them and he
you know Joe's there and so we're just
all talking yeah yeah yeah yeah and Tom
can see that I'm spinning out a little
bit
and I get in the car and you know Tom's
got a Porsche so we're like right next
to each other
and I just want to feel if it's swollen
and it is a little swollen because I
just got an injection and then and Tom's
driving and he's got his hand on the
thing he just puts his hand on my arm
and he goes you're okay he's just he's
watching he knows me so well yeah that
he knows that I'm spinning out of
control he's like you're okay
and then I was like and I felt okay I
was like you're right I'm okay what the
[__] am I doing my brain's that brain
man that guy got so much love in him
dude he does he has uh
you know
he had a fantastic relationship with his
dad
and and and I think whatever that did
that dude did to create that dude he hit
it out of the [__] park because he
has
so much
uh love that he doesn't need
reciprocated like at all like he can
just love and then he feels good for him
to give and to like take care of someone
and like you know he started the whole
birthday gift thing because and he
didn't need to he just was like hey man
I had this bike I thought you'd like it
and then of course I've turned it into a
[__] bit and now we're upside down
I'm 120 upside down on a [__] race
car that we can't make our money back on
I love it